hi I'm Nick Gillespie with Reason TV
sitting in the offices of the week the
news weekly that is all you need to know
about everything that matters with Bill
flock the editor-in-chief of the week
which started publishing seven years ago
who really basically really busy people
who want to be engaged and know what's
going on but don't have an hour or two a
day to devote to reading so we might
myself and my staff of 15 editors read
hundreds of newspapers magazines and
websites every week and basically is
still the best of what we find into
these sort of cogent pithy little
articles right independent people tend
to really enjoy our format because we're
you know we're we're an opinion magazine
board but we're not the nation sort of
preaching to that audience have
converted or the Weekly Standard
preaching to that audience
so people that like the magazine tend to
like to see both views in the same place
and go well sometimes the Liberals are
right and sometimes conservatives arrive
sometimes they both full so we're really
helping people make sense of the news
we're not in a news weekly format you
can no longer even you know hope to tell
people what happened right because
they're in fact daily newspapers can't
do that anymore either how do you guys
match up against a time or Newsweek I
mean are they or they is it finished for
them or how is it finished for them well
I you know I think they're both still
very excellent publications no I do I
admire what they do but I do think
they're they're in a bad place and that
it's unclear what their role is in this
in a sort of new media landscape and
they're you know and they'll they're
talking about the fact openly their
editors about the fact that they need to
reposition themselves I think they're
kind of from you know my perspective
they're fishing around to try to figure
out exactly
their new role is going to be and
sometimes it's trend stories sometimes
it's you know oh my aching needs a cover
story on you know osteoarthritis for the
baby boomer you should never have enough
stories about why the dinosaurs died why
the dinosaurs died and you know who was
who was Jesus really exactly and they
are you know a little lost I think
honestly and it'd still be it's
interesting to watch whether they can
sort of recreate what their what their
role is going to be you know I think
again almost a little bit by
happenstance it wasn't designed this way
originally but the week really is just
well-suited for this time when people
are really busy I mean no one works
eight hours anymore and comes home and
puts their feet up on the table it's as
well all it's time to me to read a
twenty thousand word take out on
something I mean people don't tend to
live that way they're consuming media
sort of in fits and starts and gulps
here and there and at the end of the
week we we kind of round it all up and
say look if you miss things here's the
news here's the health and science
here's the cultural stuff here's movie
reviews not just what we think about the
latest movies but here's three or four
reviewers on each on each movie these
good times or bad times for media are we
getting good news I mean is media
thriving is it dying well these are
these are interesting times for media
you know as the Chinese curse goes may
you may live in interesting times I mean
it's a it's a time of great change and
ferment and there are many wonderful
things being born and there are things
that are dying you know and it is a
clearly you know a revolutionary time
and the web is having a gigantic impact
on media you know I think in the in the
end when it all shakes out it'll
probably be a good thing for media you
know if if the New York Times manages to
create a business model whereby they
don't have to cut down trees right
and shipped them 3,000 miles in every
direction they'll eliminate 40 50
percent of their costs so but but you
know newspapers and to some extent
magazines have not yet figured out a
business model whereby you're giving
away the product on the web for free and
enough advertisement comes in to sustain
that you know I think I think quality
publications that are still delivering
what people need we'll figure out
business models that will make that work
so I think it's still really about you
know the content of what your content is
always content is king you know how do
they how do your readers respond to the
foreign foreign stories or stories about
foreign policy or about foreign country
it's a big part of our readership and
it's actually one of the things that
distinguishes us I think from from some
of the other news magazines we have an
interesting format in that again the
week we don't have reporters were
covering our own stories and and we
borrow material from other publications
so our foreign coverage consists of or
listening in essentially on what foreign
newspapers and magazines and websites
are saying in those countries and with
this very gifted foreign editor Susan
Cassie who speaks four languages and we
translate you know with the help of
stringers other things these newspapers
into English and we we have a feature
called how they see us that runs every
week where it's basically a conversation
about America or American foreign policy
has conducted it abroad that's certainly
one of the most transformational I think
elements of new media is just the the
accessibility of foreign publications of
the English British newspapers live and
when you're looking at the outdoor ears
of the world yeah and as you know you
know that the Guardian and BBC and all
those sites you know get get huge
traffic in the United States people are
listening in what are the you know what
are the three news sources that you find
you personally find you can't live
without sure well I have to say I really
think the Washington Post to me is
the best newspaper in this country and
their website is actually excellent also
they have a lot of additional content on
there I think they're a newspaper that's
adapting to the web very well with a lot
of blogs and a lot of you know sort of
very quick response and I just find
their coverage to be the most balanced
and and incisive I enjoy a slate quite a
bit actually as a web site I think they
do a really interesting job of thinking
through some of the issues and if
there's some really good writers on that
site they're good writers and I think
they present things really well and I
actually do like the BBC website and
quite a bit because again you know you
get a perspective on the news there that
I think is very useful where's the
energy in American society I mean is it
in politics as in cultures that in
business is a mix of all of these things
well certainly I think it is a mix I
mean there's a tremendous amount of
energy in all of these areas right now
you know we're still a very dynamic
society even though we have our problems
I mean there's I have to say there's
more energy in politics right now than
then I can recall probably since the
sixties and windows that mean I mean
there's more energy it's good well I
think to some extent politics has become
a form of entertainment in our culture
it's interesting I mean there are this
isn't universal but there is a large
segment of the population that follows
politics the way some people follow
survivor or American Idol you know as
like I mean if you sort of want to look
at it in a somewhat simplistic way you
know the primaries have been who's
getting kicked off the island would you
characterize yourself as the publican
Democrat liberal conservative to say
I've really become a kind of
middle-of-the-road ER
I mean I think and I think editing the
week has made me more so because you'd
be become very aware of the fact that
nobody has a monopoly on wisdom and that
I like to think that nobody has a
monopoly on stupidity and nobody has a
monopoly on stupidity either no that's
absolutely true and if you look back
historically I mean both parties have
been egregiously wrong about many many
writings and I think you know the sort
of dialectical process of banging two
ideas together produces a lot more
wisdom than one idea you know just
basically following one idea down the
track and often over a cliff because I
think any any ideology needs to be
constantly sort of tested against
reality and and that you need to make
course corrections constantly because
the world is an enormous a complex place
and any simplistic ideology I think
inevitably runs into circumstances where
it doesn't apply